catch the full podcast this Sunday with
The Man Behind KSI music the president
of misfitz boxing a co-founder of drink
Prime it's Mom's Taylor on the true
Jordie podcast tell me one of the one of
the times you remember specifically
where you were like this was biblical
Prime am I right thinking you're part of
the Prime deal as well yeah but what
happened was um we're in a group chat
six Partners was Logan one of those yes
and I think we were a week away from
launching okay and contracts were about
to be signed something happened in the
group chat where JJ got offended okay
and it wasn't because he was wrong to be
offended and it wasn't because the the
intention was to offend him at the same
time it was a total mismatch
miscommunication American and English
sense of humor not was that Logan or no
I let me let me not say more than that
it actually wasn't but um but it was it
was
misunderstanding and and it was a series
of that happening and I you know as
someone who lives in America I
understood it and I was like oh no this
is going to get taken wrong blah blah
blah so I'm just sort of like feeling
awkward and I was right JJ emailed the
lawyers hey I don't want to do this I'm
out and deleted himself from the group
chat dude when you think about what
prime has become wow yeah I mean you the
the amount of money just let's just
estimate what the what is the value
currently of prime I'd say it's about 8
to 10 billion okay so it's a it's a mega
company and at that moment you don't
know that but you know there's potential
there and you're watching it walk out
with the WhatsApp group yeah yeah no it
was bad because look the seed was
planted when I I hit Logan up and I said
I want you to be on the KSI show as the
Ghost of Christmas Past or whatever
Logan was really cool and I'd been
saying to JJ post their second fight I'm
like it's difficult to not like this guy
on impulsive I'd been watching him what
won me over going back to the incident
is when I called and called Logan and I
said hey I need to talk to you um I'm
not giving up but right now as it stands
this is what's going on and the prime
thing Logan was a [__] Superstar
about it he was
self-reflective very calm very
understanding and also he was like look
it's it's [__] cuz we've all done so
much work for this you know I mean
especially Logan JJ and the you know the
guys the other guys behind it who are
geniuses they put a lot of time effort
energy into this so the way he reacted
and the way the other guys reacted was
so cool that I then went back to JJ and
I said listen you can't just say no I'm
not doing this as a man this isn't this
isn't something that is right and he
said to me you're right you know he
didn't argue and resist it it was two
days after cuz I knew needed a cooling
off period And I said just do me one
favor we have a
call with everyone and you guys chat say
your peace they'll say their peace and
if at the end of that call you say to me
Ms don't want to do it I'll never bring
it up again you know this is the type of
older brother type advice that everyone
needs you know we all have that
hotheaded moment in US you do I do as as
men but they just have somewhere to go
just [__] and that's why I I try not
to make decisions In the Heat of the
Moment if something's happening I give
it a couple of days and then I think
about it you know and I think that's
such good advice it's the best that
might have saved this man billions like
we're not even joking that one
conversation is that domino effect that
could have changed his life even JJ was
always going to be good but this is
another level of wealth that we're
talking about going back to the music
side of things you know I remember JJ's
music Lamborghini the classics which I
still still have a place I'm a heartful
because it's like it is really a part of
his growth in YouTube history and seeing
him go from that but then see him go
from those kind of trucks um to Holiday
which was on every [__] radio
station were you in the studio when
these were being made and and was there
a moment where you were like oh oh we
got something here like what can you
take me back to those times where you
realized okay we're actually going
beyond the YouTube audience with this
yes yes you bring holiday up the label I
we sent the song it was with Jake
Gosling and digital farm animals and we
sat there and and they sent me the song
I was in LA at the time they sent me the
song and I go oh my God this is a
[__] smash this is a smash you you
got this is the next single and JJ's
like yeah but Ms you say that about
every song I'm like no no no no this
this one is is special and then sent it
to the label and God bless them BMG were
amazing with us we did a great job but
on this song they went as far as setting
up a multi uh Bader Zoom call with all
the heads of Department saying you
cannot put this song out it's [__]
[__] you can't put this song out yes you
cannot do this and think that's his
biggest hit it's his biggest hit yeah
cuz it it was everywhere it was
everywhere yeah but JJ and I we were
like we know this song is is the one you
know when you're like I can see this no
matter what anyone else tells me it
doesn't matter if if Clive Davis uh
Jimmy ivene came and said mate don't put
holid out I would still have done it JJ
would still have done it and it doesn't
mean there weren't doubts here and there
but when we when we knew we put it
together it was like this is the one I
understand in a sense of like if someone
was to say to you this ain't really KSI
or or whatever like it ain't his usual
thing but but I mean it was a it was a
classic and that it it was was very
radio friendly and anyone could listen
to it 5-year-old 50y old didn't matter
and I think that that transformed him
into a different level of artist where
even for me I'm like [__] hell he's
at Wembley Stadium singing this this is
mental like and I always thought him and
Logan were going to be big and I was
seeing that but that that was that was
the magic really that you managed to
pull together to take them to that next
level well the I understood the JJ brand
fairly and the JJ brand is to keep the
fans on their toes keep they and then
his fans have a very honest relationship
with him you know and he takes it on
when it's valid and has Merit and it's
constructive criticism he really takes
it on he does yeah um they were like oh
uh he's doing all these American
features boom we did Houdini with
English features oh he needs features
for everything boom holiday so it's all
about doing the setup and then a
surprise take them away from a natural
is that why you called it all over the
place yeah well the JJ is one of the few
artists that can hop on a house song A
hip-hop track a trap song and then a pop
song like holiday there aren't many who
can get away with that's so true I think
that's cuz he's he has a unique voice
and it is it's kind of like there's a
couple of rappers out there who can do
that but it is it is hard to do that to
just be able to transfer to any type of
music um and in terms of like where you
went from there with Misfits catch the
full podcast this
with The Man Behind KSI music the
president of misfitz boxing a co-founder
of drink Prime it's Mom's Taylor on the
true Jordi podcast